un appareil autochtone si c'est melissa
maulin depuis cette semaine j'ai reçu
une question de antoine qui me demande
j'ai déjà entendu parler dit nous des
villes est digne des forêts l'étude une
différence entre les communautés d'une
même nation antoine c'est une question
qui a quand même deux niveaux la
première c'est de dire que les innu des
villes et les zones où les forêts c'est
comme dire qu'on appartient à un ou
l'autre mais qu'on peut pas traverser
dans l'un à l'autre c'est souvent lié à
l'idée qu'on était obligé de rester dans
les réserves et qu'on sortait aussi des
réserves
et bien c'est qu'on était devenu des
nous transformer ce à dire aussi en
compte la loi sur les indiens des blancs
aux yeux de la loi
donc ça faisait en sorte que quand tu
étais en innu des forêts ou en innu des
réserves
c'est que tu étais un vrai hymne où et
quand tu étais un ou divine s'étaient
unis nous transformer qui avait perdu
l'identité la deuxième question dans la
seule question c'est dire si elle est
beaucoup d'identités différentes au sein
d'une même nation oui qu'on parle d'un
unis nous par exemple de pc mettait une
ou des couennes site soit avoir deux
cultures différentes pas parce que c'est
pas des usines ou mais parce que
territoire se transforme même si tu vas
au lac saint jean
je donne tu as existait de cet exemple
là les i nous avons écoulé piquant
porc-épic pour faire de l'artisanat et
si tu vas dans ma communauté et quanti
on va manger beaucoup plus la viande
mais presque pas utiliser le piquant
donc ce sont des différences liées au
territoire les aux traditions et même il
ya des différences au niveau
linguistique alors qu'on parle de la
situation géographique comme étant
quelque chose qui influence la culture
oui mais c'est lié au territoire mais
qu'on parle d'être en ville ou en forêt
là c'est souvent lié à l'idéologie qu'on
devait rester dans le bourg sinon
devenait des blancs alors qu'on le sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai il ya
énormément de premières nations qui se
retrouvent dans les villes et ça ne
change rien dans leur identité en tant
que première nation ou en tant
qu'autochtones dont j'espère antoine
avoir pu répondre à ta question
j'espère que vous n'hésiterez pas à nous
envoyer d'autres questions et à partager
ses vidéos sur sept une très belle
semaine